[Applauso]
[Musica]
sì
rimini
[Musica]
attacchi
tappeto
di dati
si no
[Musica]
dignità
ehi
[Musica]
[Applauso]
hey hey hey hey hey
beh
no
[Applauso]
[Musica]
d'età
capito
[Musica]
quello che avete appena visto è un
piccolo pezzo di repertorio di danza
odissi che è una danza che viene dall
est dell'india dallo stato dell'orissa
detto anch'io dice ada cui odyssey è un
antica danza di cui si trovano tracce
già nel ii secolo dopo cristo ed è una
danza di origine religiosa di origine
devozionale
un po perché una meditazione in
movimento un po perché i movimenti sono
presi dalle statue
se voi guardate i tempi dell'oristano
gli stessi movimenti senza movimento che
ho fatto io adesso è la danza in india è
sacra
si dice che ovunque una danzatrice cose
sui piedi quel suolo è sacro
ma cosa c'entro io con lo dissi che sono
nata a torino succede questo io sono
curiosa danzo da sempre nel 2009
passeggiando per torino vede una
locandina corso di danza indiana odyssey
e vedo una ragazza di schiena con dei
costumi tipo questo con questi gioielli
è già rimango abbastanza tratta e poi
vado a fare una lezione di prova questa
ragazza si chiama dafne carli e ha
portato questa danza dall'india dopo è
stata sette anni la a fare questo corso
io incontro
sarà lucrezia che sono due ragazze più
giovani di me io quando cominciò quasi
40 anni
loro invece ne hanno molti meno una
ventina in meno e poco per volta ci
appassioniamo anche sono danza molto
complessa non so se si vede e quindi a
un certo punto nella sua insegnante
invita dall'orissa due maestri indiani
molto giovani ma molto promettenti che
si chiamano lin garage pradhan e
sangiust adulta tra dan e noi facciamo
un workshop con loro di una settimana
intensissima
lavoriamo tutti i giorni un sacco di ore
al terzo giorno io non riesco neanche
più a fare le scale tanto il dolore ma
comunque andiamo avanti e loro ci danno
anche un po un compito che è quello di
diffondere lo dissi nel mondo e ci
sembra un po impegnativo comunque cosa
succede che sarà l'ok e savannah in
india due volte i momenti diverse ognuna
per conto suo
poi nel 2014 tornano questi maestri e
loro mi dicono noi andiamo in india
insieme vieni con noi e io dico ma no
certo che no ho 40 anni di più lavoro o
un menisco rotto o dei problemi di
cervicale no certo non posso venire però
quand'è che partite e parto parto e
faccio benissimo perché abbiamo la
fortuna di vivere un'esperienza
meravigliosa e molto faticosa anche nel
senso che viviamo in una casa indiana
quindi viviamo con tutte ragazze che
studiano questa danza e vengono dal
giappone dall america ad altri stati
dell'india frequentiamo una scuola
tipica indiana in india c'è molto la
tradizione del guru il maestro e ci sono
ancora scuole dove gli allievi vivono
col maestro dormono insieme mangiano
insieme cucinano insieme e noi andiamo
in una scuola fatta così una scuola
maschile tra l'altro quindi noi siamo
donne bianche e siamo le più scarse
della classe nell'ultima fila a cercare
di scimmiottare questo fa molto bene al
nostro ego herat al metodo indiano
prevede distruggere molto leggono
andiamo lezioni di danza qua ci mettiamo
in prima fila cerchiamo di farci vedere
in india invece il vero valore e essere
gli allievi del proprio maestro e
portare avanti la tradizione dei maestri
comunque questa esperienza indiana e
faticosissima perché il nostro corpo non
è proprio abituato né a quel caldo né a
quei movimenti li quindi abbiamo proprio
il dolore nelle ossa e la fatica noi non
abbiamo quell'apertura delle anche che
hanno gli indiani che si siedono a gambe
incrociate sempre noi non siamo capaci a
stare tutte quelle ore a fare le stesse
cose
in più c'è proprio una cultura diversa
per esempio in india vi può capitare che
qualcuno mi inviti a cena a casa non vi
stupite la cena è tutto il contrario
come un film arrotolato nel senso che
normalmente noi andiamo a cena da
qualcuno mangiamo e poi chiacchieriamo
in india va al contrario va arrivate a
cena chiacchierate ore
di solito gli uomini intrattengono gli
ospiti le donne cucinano finita questa
fase si mangia e appena avete finito di
mangiare arriva qualcuno che vi
accompagna alla porta e dice and now you
go ora vai e giudici ma cosa ho
sbagliato cosa ho fatto che non va
niente semplicemente la parte conviviale
prima quindi insomma in tutte queste
fatiche proprio la fatica anche fisica
lo spaesamento tutte le abitudini
diverse ogni tanto e faticoso
diciamo che ogni tanto viene qualche
momento di sconforto però io ho una
bella squadra
non c'è un proverbio indiano che dice
quando vedi tutto grigio sposta
l'elefante allora io da solo provato a
spostare elefante ma quando è il dolore
nelle ginocchia il sudore tutte le parti
fa caldo è l'elefante non si vuole
spostare è pesante e forte e non vi darà
retta ma se ci provate con qualcun altro
io avevo le mie due amiche
avevo i miei due maestre brolin garage
san giusto insomma tutti insieme a furia
di spingere l'elefante poco per volta
sia riuscito ad allontanarlo quando
siamo tornate in italia con le mie doni
che abbiamo aperto un gruppo che si
chiama kalinga abbiamo cominciato a fare
performance come quella che avete visto
adesso tutto questo per raccontarvi che
cosa
cosa ha insegnato a me lo disse a me
assegnato questo se c'è qualcosa che ci
piace
non ci sono scuse non c'è il menisco
tutte le scuse che vi raccontavo io
abbiamo veramente tutti il diritto di
essere felice di cercare una vita che
perlomeno ci assomigli quindi il mio
suggerimento è questo se c'è qualcosa
che mi piace che vi appassiona partite
partite subito e immergetevi
completamente nel bene e nel male con le
lacrime il sudore con tutte queste cose
le risate perché ci sono anche quelle
e se potete fatelo con qualcuno perché è
qui vi viene in aiuto invece un
proverbio africano
se è vero che da soli si va più veloce
insieme si va più lontano
grazie